thank you
[Music]
anyone who's married will have a very
valuable opinion on this one so you know
the famous actor Kevin Costner
he's going through a divorce right now
with his wife oh Kevin Costner yeah and
they've got a I think their house just
the house alone is like 145 million
dollar damn wow something crazy so uh
they have kids and everything in the
prenuptial agreement however it does
state that if they were to get a divorce
his wife would have to leave the house
she can't live there she would have to
find her own place to live but it has
also stated that he has to give her a
million dollars as a way to like start
up looking for a place to live
alternatively but she's refusing to go
why she owns more money probably yeah
but there's no way to get it because
their prenuptial agreement was very set
in stone and specific wow but um she's
refusing to leave saying that Kevin
Costner is trying to force her into
homelessness even though he is giving
her money but one million dollars is not
a lot if if you live in the 100 million
dollar home and have a massage from
okay from Mel Gibson
we don't know
we're a million could buy everything the
million maybe not be worth as much as it
as it was back yeah I can't live like
these middle class peasants with a
million dollar home that's what she's
saying basically keep up the lifestyle
yeah it is done I'm sure that is a big
argument in like divorce cases right
when it when it comes down to like child
support and all that absolutely yeah
like they do factor in like this was my
lifestyle I had before and it must be
maintained right which is kind of like a
that's weird yeah I do think the
contract is the contract though yeah
like if that's what you signed you
should have updated it yeah like if you
signed it then that's where you're
supposed to uphold yeah they could have
like renegotiated
it'll be like hey can we like up this
because and then get a divorce next week
yeah yeah because
um I heard that in California like a lot
of the times prenups get thrown out and
then they really yeah it's pretty yeah
yeah that's that's I've seen that a lot
I heard that like
um
even if you don't get married but you
are what is it cohabitating or whatever
if you just live together over 10 years
you're considered married by the state
so what sucks is you don't even get to
file taxes and like benefit together and
get all those things but then
um if you do separate there it's on
grounds of like you can't be treated as
if you're married so I'm like that
doesn't make any sense that's a little
weird because what if one was like
making more than the other or whatever
and then like now you're entitled to
half and then like but then you didn't
benefit from the tax deductions and all
that stuff it's [__] weird yeah it's
hard because there are such clear
um distinctions within the prenup that
are obviously not advantageous to her
side but she signed it like he gets to
keep the blue bike
he gets to keep the wheels he takes the
seat he has a Nintendo she gets the Sega
Genesis but there's no games on it
the team
Breadwinner and she was kind of like a
note uh or she's like an actress well
that's the thing it's scaled so like
let's say a woman like her to like us
would be like wow you know but for him a
net worth of 250 million and go and
growing she's really like down there
compared to him
almost like he elevated her status or
whatever yeah it says here that he had
funded like when they were still married
he had funded her businesses which both
failed so like you know and then that at
the end when she was seeking a lawyer to
help handle this whole uh debacle she
used his credit card charged ninety six
thousand dollars for the expenses on
that so he's like you're using my money
to get more money from me yeah and in
the agreement she's trying to say that
like oh he's trying to kick me and my
children out so that we're homeless and
he's like no honey just you yeah it says
distinctly the kids are free to choose
wherever they want to go at any time
they can go to your place they can go to
mine they can go to a shitty million
dollar Place yeah
[Applause]
exactly they can go to your Palazzo
estate yeah it's like a thing where he's
like not saying they have to leave he's
saying now they get a choice Kevin
Costner saying there's a problem you
have not made the other place for them
to choose
Ah that's the thing and she's like
saying we have nowhere to go he's like
you didn't get a place honey
yeah it's it's one of those things where
like she's sending out all these public
statements about things that he's doing
and he just keeps putting the original
contract out where it literally says
that in the paper is the are the kids
older they're they're not older but they
are like I don't know it's hard to tell
they look like freaking models
yeah oh he's got little ones damn that
kind of sucks you want kids like that
huh pretty good yeah Kevin costumes are
so messy really good yeah so it's for me
I'm like aside from the money [__] like
damn you just couldn't compromise or
solve it huh with the little ones around
yeah and because sometimes I'm like if
y'all ain't [__]
beating each other up and it's not crazy
where everyone's drunk all day and it's
like really [__] bad because some
people just need to get away from each
other but if it's like dude you already
disinvested you got kids and it's just
it's because you're just not working out
and it's like I'm like what's the real
reason all right you think she's very
reasonable this lady I have no idea but
I would like to believe as a man that
she crazy
but then I also believe like this is my
stereotype about hello rich people is
like it's like they don't like
discomfort and if they could pay for it
they'll just deal with it and then I'm
like it could be at this point where you
know
they're just like ah [__] I don't this
is inconvenience so she's the one filing
for divorce oh so it's not him okay it's
not him okay she is probably just crazy
there but she's also the one that that
Kevin Costner's lawyers are stating that
is not answering whenever they're like
hey did you do this did you do that you
know she's just not responding so
they're like how can we move this
forward because they're supposed to give
her a million bucks plus 200 Grand in
the first year to like help with things
pay for insurance pay for like things
like that if she was caught or like if
he was caught cheating right doesn't
that void the marriage it may but in
this filing it I think it's just
irreconcilable differences I don't think
it's a no but then like I'm saying if
like you wrote a prenup in normal and
then you had him yeah that means that
the the marriage was the right to clean
up
no like like you violated the marriage
because you violated the contract right
no longer I've seen that happen I don't
know if that would because in okay so
that's one of the things is that if she
was filing for divorce because he
violated the marriage contract then the
prenup would be void but in this case
it's it's not
so it's just a preference so you're like
I don't love you anymore yeah if you
file under irreconcilable differences
there's no blame on either side I feel
like those are so stupid yeah this is
the most common though because they're
like it's such a selfish thing if you
have children to do just mommy daddy
just don't get along anymore it's like
are you screaming and [__] throwing
plates at each other no then being an
adult and figure it out work it out the
idea of like I think that's funny to
look at these problems in scale it's
like somebody's giving you a million
dollars to go get a place for you and
your kids okay I'll take it let's go for
people like us we can think of so many
ways yeah but like for them is that the
equivalent of sending us away with like
a I don't know 800 bucks probably by
scale because by scale like let's say an
average home would be 1.4 million right
for like a upper middle class or for
them to stay in the neighborhood that's
familiar to them that's like giving her
140 Grand
um
that's the equivalent because their home
is like 140 million 145 mil and then so
they're giving them a million plus I
know that when you have that divorce
it's like lawful to try to keep the kids
within the community that they are used
to right yeah so you can't just make
them live in Mid City actually it's like
giving them 10 grand not 100 yeah yeah
yeah
how fast do you think they blow through
money with the lifestyle that the kids
are used to it must be pretty quick
right yeah but just make [__] Kevin
Costner pay for it all you know
well the money's for her to do anyway
right the money's for her right and who
knows how much she has like from her own
whatever but that million is supposed to
be her move money and then the the Kevin
Costner never said he's cutting out the
kids they can choose where to live but
that's separate yeah I think I think she
can't really have grounds of like well
the kids need money for child support
for that little detail about her having
two failed businesses that she that he
funded what do you does that isn't that
a great look I mean also don't most like
first businesses fail
depends on what it is for the most I
mean but you're also like the
resourcefulness of people like that and
the money that they have you would
assume that they probably have you know
people in positions to do jobs well
enough to not fail and to have your
husband endorse it hey right your house
is worth 145 million dollars you should
just like build up her own little house
on the plot same place
if your house is that expensive you
could have a back house
his argument his argument is that Kevin
Costner right now is getting ready for
like he's invested in this massive like
I believe it's like a Trilogy or like a
movie deal or something and he needs to
not see her around because it it's
damaging to his mentality while he's
focusing on this thing bodyguard too
that's really [__] good but she's the
one for it she's the one that filed for
it right so he's saying like for his own
mental health he would prefer that the
prenup and everything go through so he
can focus on his stuff and she's not
always around because she's not leaving
that's the problem he's like it stays
here you gotta go why is she having a
tantrum because I don't think I don't
think her side of the of the uh of the
litigation believes that the prenup
should be applied or they don't think
it's a loss so it's now she has to make
moves to because if she does leave then
it's all said and done if she wants to
extract more to what she thinks she's
entitled to it might be her last stand
right okay okay it might be that might
be why what are what are the uh
commenters saying I haven't seen any
comments about it but I could probably
guess that you know men and women will
be pretty divided
I don't think so
I think women are pretty clear-cut on
this
yeah what do you think the woman gonna
say
they're team Costner dude also also it
should be noted that 145 million dollar
house he bought it before they were
married from The Bodyguard yeah
damn so that's his [__] he let her move
in let her move in yes yeah what's the
most Banger Kevin Costner get her the
[__] out of there man he earned all that
[__] which one the highest chances
dude yeah if he bought that [__] and
then she came into his life
you believe in prenup
I think if I could if I were to defend
her it would be like 145. it would be
at what like how she supported him
during what phases of life and like
sacrifices she made to right to to be
with the value for yeah like if she if
she was giving up something like if she
if you could clearly show that she had
something going on but how do you yeah
and then she gave that up like let's say
like she had a job that would pay x
amount per year and she gave that up to
do other things with him she would say
well
these period of time let's say like five
years of being with you before the
divorce I would have made x amount
um she could barely argued dude she was
she was probably helping him out so much
she was probably doing that I'm sure she
was she was doing it she was doing the
self tapes dude she was probably reading
the other side
he's all doing the he was all doing The
Bodyguard lines and then he's like no no
no no no no honey it's it's this it's a
little pitchy but
people
foreign